>> Jon Parrish Peede:
Good afternoon,
and welcome to the
18th Annual Library
of Congress National
Book Festival.
I'm Jon Parrish Peede, chairman
of the National Endowment
for the Humanities.
NEH is proud to sponsor this
year's Understanding Our
World Stage.
An independent federal agency,
NEH was established in 1965
and our agency was part of
LBJ's Great Society legislation.
And the NEH and our sister
agency the NEA still follow
that original mission.
Our agency supports museum
exhibitions, documentaries,
books that bring history,
literature, philosophy,
archaeology and other
humanities fields to the public.
We fund a preservation
of historical records,
collections and objects.
We sponsor educational
opportunities for teachers
and students in the humanities.
And we underwrite fundamental
research across all disciplines
of the humanities both
by professors as well
as by independent scholars.
Our distinguished guest today,
Gordon S. Wood, has
long ties to NEH.
Not only has he received NEH
grants as far back as 1967,
some 50 years ago when we
were an infant federal agency,
he was awarded the 2010
National Humanities medal
by the president of
the United States.
And you will have a chance
to meet him yourself shortly
after this presentation at 6:30
PM where he'll be signing books
at line number 11
on the lower level.
And I'll say both to this
audience and to the public
at large, Gordon Wood hardly
needs an introduction.
Once described as "almost
an American institution"
by the New York Times, Wood
has profoundly shaped our
understanding of America's
democratic institutions
and the visions of the founders
who laid out their blueprint.
He is the author and
the editor of 25 books,
including the Pulitzer
Prize-winning The Radicalism
of the American Revolution,
and The Creation
of the American Republic
for which he was awarded
the Bancroft Prize.
He is the Alba Way University
professor and professor
of history emeritus
at Brown University.
And I'll say too on a personal
note, I had the pleasure
of going to grad school
with his daughter Amy
who is herself a fine
and important historian.
And throughout his long career
as a historian, Wood has focused
on the pivotal period after 1776
in which our nation was forged,
and unpack for us the essential
radicalism of the founding era.
In a letter dated
July1813, John Adams wrote
to his political rival
and sometimes friend Thomas
Jefferson, "You and I ought not
to die before we have explained
ourselves to each other."
And of course, the latest book
that we're celebrating today,
Friends Divided: John
Adams and Thomas Jefferson,
Wood fulfills Adams'
wish, explaining the ideas
that brought these
two men together,
and the philosophical
differences that led
to the original schism
in their friendship.
And I will say that these
letters are compiled,
edited and published through
decades of NEH support.
And since we are a
federally funded agency,
that is through your support.
So thank you.
Professor Wood will be in
conversation with philanthropist
and cofounder of the Carlisle
Group David Rubenstein.
Deeply invested in the practice
of patriotic philanthropy,
Rubenstein's generosity has done
much to preserve the monuments
and records of our founding era.
Those of us in DC are grateful
to his financial support
in creating the National
Archives Visiting Center,
repairing the Washington
Monument after it was damaged
by the earthquake, and
sponsoring the current expansion
of the Kennedy Center.
And of course I would be
remiss if I did not say
that the book festival
as we know it simply
would not be occurring
without his support, his
vision and sponsorship.
[ Applause ]
Thank you.
And if you'll allow me a
few sentences before we get
to the main event, what comes
to mind for me when I think
about these gentlemen and what
they have achieved is an 1816
letter that Jefferson wrote.
And he said, "A nation that
expects to be ignorant and free,
and a state, a civilization
expects what never was
and never will be."
So ladies and gentlemen,
please help me welcome these two
gentlemen who have done as much
as anyone I can think
of as living Americans
to help us have a society that
is both free and informed.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> David Rubenstein:
So why don't we start
with the second Continental
Congress.
At that congress, John Adams
is the dominant figure.
Is that fair to say?
>> Gordon Wood: Yes,
by all means.
>> David Rubenstein:
And he was dominant
because he was the
principal person who thought
that we should secede
from the British Empire.
>> Gordon Wood: Right.
>> David Rubenstein:
So he was then probably
in his 40's I guess it was.
And Thomas Jefferson was new.
He hadn't been at the
first Continental Congress.
>> Gordon Wood: That's right.
>> David Rubenstein: He comes
for the second Continental
Congress.
He's only 33 or so.
He goes begrudgingly.
He doesn't really
want to be there.
Is that right?
>> Gordon Wood: No, I think
he wanted to go to the first,
but he became ill and he
sent a pamphlet instead,
or some instructions which
turned into a pamphlet.
His fellow delegates from
Virginia published it
without his permission and it
became the most radical pamphlet
at that time in the whole
debate with Great Britain.
This was a summary view
of the relationship.
And until Thomas
Payne's Common Sense,
it was the most radical
pamphlet.
>> David Rubenstein:
Okay, so he goes there.
His wife was ill at the time of
the second Continental Congress.
He didn't really want
to be there, I thought.
But he gets there and ultimately
John Adams proposes a resolution
in effect that says we should
break away from England.
Is that right?
>> Gordon Wood: Right.
Well, others proposed
the resolution
but certainly he
was the proponent,
the most eager delegate
for independence.
>> David Rubenstein: Okay,
so he's the most eager
delegate for independence.
And ultimately the
delegates don't have the right
to break away from England.
They haven't been given that
authority from the legislatures.
So I think Adams and Richard
Henry Lee basically say
to the delegates, "Let's
pass a resolution to go back
and get the authority."
Is that more or less right?
>> Gordon Wood: Well,
they pass in May --
the 2nd of May, the
May Resolutions,
which essentially
were written by Adams.
>> David Rubenstein: Right.
>> Gordon Wood: And they
essentially gave advice
to the colonies that they
should suppress all mention
of royal authority.
So it's tantamount to a
Declaration of Independence
which Adams felt was the real
Declaration of Independence.
>> David Rubenstein: Okay.
We'll get to that.
>> Gordon Wood: Of course
later on he tried to claim
that he had anticipated the --
>> David Rubenstein: Right.
So the delegates go back
to their 13 colonies.
But while they're back, there's
a committee that's appointed
to deal with this situation.
If they come back and they
vote for independence,
they want to explain
why they're doing this.
>> Gordon Wood: Right.
>> David Rubenstein: So they
decide to have a committee,
and there were lots
of committees
in those days in the congress.
But they have a committee
appointed to figure
out how they should describe
what they're going to do.
And who's on that committee?
>> Gordon Wood: Well,
five representatives.
And they're sectionally,
depending on location,
a New Englander, a New
Yorker -- two New Englanders,
a New Yorker and a Virginian.
Yeah, and so they
represent, and Jefferson
and Adams are both
on the committee.
>> David Rubenstein: Right.
>> Gordon Wood: Jefferson's
the young man.
Adams is on about two dozen
committees in the congress.
So he's on the board of law
which is essentially
conducting the war effort
against Great Britain.
So he's very busy, and so
let's let this young guy
who just joined us, let him
go off and write the thing.
>> David Rubenstein: Okay.
>> Gordon Wood: Little did
Adams realize how important the
Declaration would become.
He would have written
it himself.
He was appalled later on
of course by the acclaim
that Jefferson was getting.
Neither Jefferson nor Adams knew
how important the Declaration
would become in time.
>> David Rubenstein: Adams
I thought originally said
something like, "Well, I'm not
that popular and you are not
as disliked as I am, so
you should write it."
But also he was from
Massachusetts and maybe someone
from Virginia would be better.
Is that more or less right?
>> Gordon Wood: Yeah,
that was true.
Both colonies were of
course in the lead.
But Adams also said, "You're
a good man with a pen."
Because of the summary
view pamphlet,
Jefferson had already acquired
a reputation for being facile
and good in his writing.
So it was a natural thing.
But Jefferson was a junior
member and it was not at all
in Adams' mind that
this was going to amount
to anything important.
>> David Rubenstein:
So Jefferson has roughly I
think 17 days to write it.
Like most humans, he
waits till the end.
So he has three days
to go, he sits down
and writes the Declaration
of Independence,
takes it back to the committee.
And the committee, they're
happy with it and they edit it.
>> Gordon Wood: They make a
few changes, but minor things.
And yeah, Jefferson.
>> David Rubenstein:
And one of the people
on the committee is an editor
named Benjamin Franklin,
so he edits a little bit.
>> Gordon Wood: Right.
>> David Rubenstein: All right.
So then the delegates come back,
they vote ultimately
to be independent.
That vote occurs
on July the 2nd.
So what does Adams
say to his wife then?
>> Gordon Wood: Well, he
thought that would be the day
that would be celebrated
with bonfires and fireworks
and what became the 4th of July.
He missed it by two days.
He didn't realize that
the actual Declaration
or the document would
become the important thing,
rather than the vote itself.
And so he missed that.
But he got the notion that
it was important right.
>> David Rubenstein: Okay.
So on July the 2nd they
vote to be independent.
July the 3rd, July the 4th,
they take up the
Declaration of Independence.
And do they just take
whatever Jefferson has written?
Or do they modify it?
>> Gordon Wood: No, no,
they make some changes.
>> David Rubenstein: Right.
>> Gordon Wood: The congress
makes some very serious changes.
About 40% of the Declaration
is changed, particularly
on the slavery question.
And Jefferson is suffering
through all of these changes.
Franklin makes jokes
to him about it,
referring to a hatter I
think, a sign and so on.
And it becomes a humorous
incident, but not for Jefferson.
He really suffered.
No author likes to
have his words cut out.
>> David Rubenstein: During
this debate it's alleged
that Jefferson never
said a word.
He didn't say, "Don't
edit this."
He says nothing.
>> Gordon Wood: Right.
>> David Rubenstein:
Why did he say nothing?
>> Gordon Wood: He differs
to -- he's not a public man.
He does not like speaking out.
He was good in small committees,
but he's not an orator.
Completely different from
Adams in that respect.
Adams is always on his feet,
always arguing and
always debating.
Jefferson, not at all.
>> David Rubenstein: Okay,
so ultimately they agree
on the text on the 4th of July.
It's printed up, it's
sent around to everybody.
They know what the text is
and then the Continental
Congress more or less disbands
as they go to fight the war.
Where does Adams go and
where does Jefferson go
after the second
Continental Congress?
What are they doing?
>> Gordon Wood: Well, Adams is
finally assigned to go abroad
to negotiate a treaty.
He's going to negotiate the
treaty with France, an alliance.
And he arrives but it's already
then accomplished by others,
including of course
Franklin who has been there
from the very beginning, 1776.
And so Adams is over there and
so he's got nothing else to do,
so he goes to Holland and
becomes a very important figure
in extracting money from the
Dutch and also getting the Dutch
to become the second country
to recognize the United States.
And Jefferson goes back
home and eventually ends
up becoming governor of the
state, of the commonwealth
of Virginia, the new state.
And a very unhappy
experience for him
because he mishandles
some events.
But he would love to get abroad
himself, and is asked later,
but can't leave because of
first there are difficulties
with the ships, and then
there's difficulties
with his wife's illness.
>> David Rubenstein: But in that
period of time, during the war,
when the war is being fought
from essentially 1776 to 1781,
the relationship between
Adams and Jefferson is okay?
>> Gordon Wood: Yeah.
I think there's one
letter exchanged.
They had known each other,
but they're not close
until Jefferson finally comes
abroad as one of the ministers
to deal with treaties
of commerce following
the acceptance
of the peace treaty
by Great Britain.
So when they're together
in Paris,
that's when the two families
really come together.
Or Jefferson's a
widower at this point.
And Abigail has joined John
and John Quincy Adams
the young son is there.
And Jefferson is adopted so to
speak as a member of the family.
He's lonely.
He's got his daughters there,
but the daughters are in school.
And he becomes a member of the
Adams family and takes to them.
Really I think that's when the
relationship is most enriched.
They become intermingled.
Jefferson would take John Quincy
to a concert or to a museum.
They would go to places
in Paris together.
And then of course when Adams
is appointed as minister
of the United States to Great
Britain, they go off to London
but they exchange
letters back and forth.
Abigail herself writing
to Thomas Jefferson,
and they exchange presents.
And there's a little
flirtation that goes
on between Jefferson --
not much by our standards.
But in one letter Jefferson
writes to Abigail, "I was going
to purchase a little statue
of Venus for your dining room,
but then I realized
that having two Venuses
in the same room
would be too much."
[ Laughter ]
That's Jefferson
flirting with Abigail.
He's really taken with Abigail.
He never has met a woman
like her who knew so much
about literature, who had read
the same things he had read,
Shakespeare, Milton.
She could quote things
from memory,
and at the same time
was a household manager.
And the combination to
him was just overwhelming.
And he really is taken
with the Adams family.
I think that's the point where
the two men really are close.
And the bonds of
affection are really sealed.
>> David Rubenstein: When
Jefferson is over there,
he asked to have his younger
daughter sent over to France
so he could meet with her.
>> Gordon Wood: Right.
>> David Rubenstein: He hadn't
seen her in a couple years.
The daughter didn't want to go,
but eventually they trick her
into going on a boat
and she's accompanied
by a young slave
whose name is --
>> Gordon Wood: Sally Hemmings.
And Sally Hemmings and
Polly come to London first.
And Abigail takes
them in and hosts them
for a few weeks waiting
for Jefferson to come
to London to pick them up.
But Jefferson doesn't do that,
much to Abigail's surprise.
He sends another person, an
agent, to pick up his daughter.
That's when Sally joins
the Jefferson household.
>> David Rubenstein: Right.
She's 14 years old.
>> Gordon Wood: Very
young at that point.
And presumably she's
one of these young women
who really blossomed in
the next couple of years.
By the time she's 16,
she's a woman instead of --
>> David Rubenstein:
The age of consent
in Virginia in those
days was 12.
>> Gordon Wood: Well, I don't
think there was much in terms
of consent needed in this case.
But this is the relationship
with Sally as a concubine.
And it's the Paris experience
that helps explain it.
Because Sally came --
her brother was already
there, James.
James Hemmings has been
brought over by Jefferson
to learn how to cook
French style.
And he's going to come
back to Monticello
and become the chef
at Monticello.
Being in France -- and James is
older than Sally, he's about 20.
He realizes he can
walk out the door
and be free under French law.
He uses that leverage
to negotiate a deal
with Jefferson that, "Look, I
will come back to Monticello
and train another servant,"
as Jefferson referred to them,
"to learn how to cook French
style, if you then free me."
Jefferson does that,
makes that deal.
And presumably he makes the same
deal with James sister Sally.
Which she does not
want to be freed,
but she wants her children
freed when they're adults.
And that's the deal.
As one of the Hemmings
boys, offspring,
Jefferson's offspring
says later in his memoir,
"The deal that my mother
made with Mr. Jefferson."
>> David Rubenstein:
That's Madison.
>> Gordon Wood: Madison
Hemmings.
>> David Rubenstein: Did
Jefferson honor that commitment?
>> Gordon Wood: Yes, he does.
Of course, by that time, the law
in Virginia was they
were octoroons.
That is the boys, the
Hemmings are octoroons.
They're one-eighth black
and there's no one-drop rule
in Virginia at that point.
And they are legally white.
And so as you know
today, when the Hemmings
and Jefferson heirs
get together,
many of the Hemmings heirs are
white and others are black.
So some of the Hemmings
successors passed as white.
They were only one-eighth white.
Sally herself was a quadroon,
so she was the half-sister,
if you can believe this,
of Jefferson's wife.
>> David Rubenstein:
In other words,
Sally Hemmings father
was a white slave owner,
but he was also the father
of Jefferson's wife, right?
>> Gordon Wood: Betty Hemmings.
He's the father of
Jefferson's wife,
but he also has a
concubine himself,
Betty Hemmings who
was herself half.
>> David Rubenstein: Right.
So some people say
when Jefferson saw
this 14-year-old girl,
he was seeing his
wife as a younger --
>> Gordon Wood: Well,
he could be.
She may have resembled,
since she's the half-sister,
she may have resembled.
>> David Rubenstein:
So let's go back
to the Jefferson/Adams
relationship.
So George Washington
is elected president
of the United States
unanimously,
and John Adams is
elected vice president.
>> Gordon Wood: Right.
>> David Rubenstein:
And this is in 1790.
>> Gordon Wood: 1788 was
the election, and 1789.
>> David Rubenstein:
Right, 1788, right.
And they take office in 1789.
>> Gordon Wood: Right.
>> David Rubenstein: So
Jefferson is still in France.
He comes back and three months
after the election,
he's told what?
>> Gordon Wood: Well, he finds
out that Washington has
appointed him secretary of state
without informing
him that he was going
to be secretary of state.
And he takes the position.
It's a great honor.
>> David Rubenstein: Okay, so
he becomes secretary of state.
And eventually Jefferson falls
out with Washington
and he resigns.
>> Gordon Wood: Right.
>> David Rubenstein: Why did
he fall out with Washington?
>> Gordon Wood: Well,
he and Hamilton clash.
They had very different views.
Hamilton has a program to
makeover the United States
in the image of Great Britain,
a fiscal military state,
a standing army with debt,
solving the debt problem
of consolidating the debt,
and making the United States
in time a nation that could take
on the European states
on their own terms.
That's very different from
the vision that Jefferson has.
He wants a very different
-- Jefferson is a radical,
a liberal radical of the 18th
century who feels that armies
and war machines are dangerous.
They lead to fighting and
they can only cause harm
to the international order.
And so Jefferson is
as radical a liberal
as an elected official could be.
He and Thomas Payne
do not differ one bit
in their ideas of government.
Adams is a very different
kind of person.
He's a conservative.
>> David Rubenstein: So
Washington serves two terms
and decides not to
serve a third.
He could serve presumably.
>> Gordon Wood: Right.
>> David Rubenstein: There's
no prohibition at that time.
So then who's running
for president then?
>> Gordon Wood: Well,
Adams assumes
that he would be the
natural successor,
and he's a little surprised
to see the emerging new party,
the Republican party
led by Madison
and Jefferson is the candidate.
And Jefferson comes in
second in electoral votes.
In those days the
party system was not --
we don't have the
12th Amendment.
So the person that got the
most electoral votes gets
to be president.
The person who gets the second
most electoral votes gets
to be vice president.
And so you have this
awkward situation
where a federalist Adams is
president and a Republican,
an opposition party --
although these parties are not
like our modern parties --
the opposition party
is the vice president.
>> David Rubenstein:
In those days,
the vice president didn't
have that much to do,
maybe preside over the Senate.
But the Congress is only
meeting a couple months a year.
So Jefferson really
doesn't spend
that much time with
Adams at all.
>> Gordon Wood: Right.
At first Jefferson thought
that this was ideal.
He actually differs to Adams.
And he thought maybe this would
end the partisan conflict.
And he writes a letter to
Adams more or less asking
for kind of accommodation.
"Look, we can get
along and so on."
But he says, "I better show this
to my colleague James Madison."
And Madison says,
"Don't send that letter."
Madison is far shrewder in
that sense politically, says,
"That's going to cause
you embarrassment later
because this conflict between
us," meaning the Republicans
and the federalists,
"is not normal politics.
That's going to become more
serious and that letter's going
to come back and haunt you."
So Jefferson does not send it.
And he simply withdraws
from the government,
does not get involved.
And Adams comes to realize
that his fellow federalists
do not want Jefferson
or Madison involved in
the government at all.
And you have a really serious
split between the two parties,
much more serious than
anything we have today,
as hard as that may
be to believe.
>> David Rubenstein: Right.
So Adams is, like
most presidents,
going to run for a second term.
And he runs for a second
term and is it easy
for him to get elected again?
>> Gordon Wood: He assumed
that he would be easily
elected the way Washington was.
But suddenly his
former friend ousts him.
>> David Rubenstein: Jefferson.
>> Gordon Wood: Jefferson
gets more electoral votes
and Adams is humiliated.
He's furious.
And he refuses to attend
Jefferson's inaugural and leaves
on a 4:00 stage that day.
The only other person who did
that was John Quincy Adams
his son when he's ousted
after one term by
Andrew Jackson.
>> David Rubenstein: So
Adams takes the carriage back
to Raintree, Massachusetts.
>> Gordon Wood: Right.
>> David Rubenstein: But how
long does that actually take
to get there in those days?
>> Gordon Wood: Oh,
several days.
A week or more.
>> David Rubenstein: Okay.
>> Gordon Wood: Yeah.
>> David Rubenstein: So
Jefferson's president,
Adams is stewing
in Massachusetts.
Did they have any
conversation or correspondence
in that period of time?
>> Gordon Wood: No,
not after 1800.
>> David Rubenstein:
So for eight years
they essentially had
no communication?
>> Gordon Wood: Right.
Well, Abigail writes in 1804
when Polly the young daughter
that she had hosted
in London dies.
And so she had just lost a son,
so she's feeling very
sympathetic towards Jefferson.
She writes a letter of
condolence to Jefferson.
And Jefferson takes it
and I think assumes more
than he should have,
because he writes back a very
friendly letter.
Except at the end of the letter
he says, "Look, your husband
and I have agreed on every
issue," which is not true.
Jefferson was of course
notoriously disingenuous
in his correspondence
with people.
He said, "We agreed
on almost everything.
There's only one
thing that I objected
to in your husband's
administration,
and that was the appointment
of the midnight judges."
>> David Rubenstein: These
were judges right before Adams
left office.
>> Gordon Wood: Right.
Adams is elected in November,
but in those days the new
president did not take office
until March.
So Adams in that interval
appoints a whole bunch
of judges including John Marshal
as the chief justice
of the Supreme Court.
Jefferson and the
Republicans are furious
at those appointments,
and as soon as they get
into office they eliminate
this whole appellate system
that Adams had.
But he makes that criticism.
"That's the only thing, Mrs.
Adams, that I objected to."
Well, that's not
satisfactory to Abigail.
She's furious.
She comes back with an
attack on Jefferson,
defending her husband.
And Jefferson writes back
trying to accommodate her.
And she comes back even
harsher the next letter.
And Jefferson throws up
his hands and gives up.
If he had avoided that, I think
it might have led to something.
If he avoided criticizing
Mr. Adams in any way,
Abigail might have
gotten her husband
into correspondence
with Jefferson.
>> David Rubenstein: Is
there any lingering animosity
because July the 2nd is not
considered the big day compared
to July the 4th?
Or that's not a problem?
>> Gordon Wood: No,
I don't think so.
The problem comes when July the
4th and the Declaration itself,
the written document, takes
on enhanced importance.
And that starts in the '90's.
The break from England
which was the important part
in 1776 is irrelevant
by the 1790's.
But what's important is
the second paragraph,
"All men are created
equal," and so on.
That becomes the rallying
cry of the Republican party.
And Jefferson is extolled as the
leader of the Republican party
who had written these
famous words.
And Jefferson suddenly realizes,
well, this is really important.
He had no idea in 1776 it
would become important.
And so at this point in
the early 19th century,
he writes to his
son-in-law, "Look,
the desk on which I wrote
the Declaration is going
to become a relic.
I'm going to give it to you."
He realizes that this is
going to make him famous.
>> David Rubenstein: Wow.
>> Gordon Wood: It really
is an extraordinary change.
And of course it drives
John Adams jealous.
I mean, he's so jealous
of this reputation
that Jefferson has acquired.
And Jefferson of course lists
that as the first
accomplishment he wants posted
on his gravestone.
>> David Rubenstein:
So ultimately,
Jefferson finishes his
two terms as president
and he goes back to
Monticello, right?
>> Gordon Wood: Right.
>> David Rubenstein: And then
somebody decides it would be a
good idea for Adams
and Jefferson
to kind of be friendlier.
>> Gordon Wood: Benjamin
Rush who is a mutual friend,
though he's closer to Adams
than he is to Jefferson,
works two years to
bring these two men,
these two patriots
back together.
He thinks it's important for
the country that the northerner
and the southerner
should correspond.
And he's the person
that made it possible
for them to come together.
And finally he's saying, "He
loves you, he loves you."
And finally Adams
writes a letter
to Jefferson and breaks the ice.
And then the letters flow
for the next 14 years.
With Adams writing about two
to every one of Jefferson's.
Jefferson's embarrassed by that
and Adams says, "Well, look,
you're probably busier
than I am."
So he asks him, "How many
letters did you receive
last year?"
And this is 1820.
And Jefferson says, "Well, I
received 1,200 and something."
Adams is appalled
and embarrassed.
He says, "I only received 120."
I mean one-tenth of what --
you see, Jefferson is an
international superstar already.
He's corresponding with
the czar of Russia,
with Alexander Humboldt,
the great German naturalist.
There's no comparison.
Adams is in a different league,
celebrity league,
than Jefferson.
And that's still true.
I mean, we have this great
monument in this city
to Jefferson right off the
tidal basin, right off the maw.
Monticello is vised by hundreds
of thousands of people
every year.
There's nothing like
that number that go
to Adams' home in Quincy.
In fact, I found out recently
that during the offseason,
they close the place,
his home, on weekends.
The National Park
Service runs it.
The two men are in two
different spheres of celebrity,
and that was true then
and it's still true today.
>> David Rubenstein:
Now 50 years to the day
after the Declaration of
Independence is agreed to,
both men are ill and
what happens to them?
>> Gordon Wood: Well, as
everyone seems to know
or most people know, they died
on the same day, July 4th,
the jubilee celebration,
50 years since 1776.
And it's such a coincidence that
the nation can only conclude
that its providential.
Of course, there's a
little bit of manipulation.
These men are dying but they're
hanging on as best they can
because they know the
importance of July 4th.
And Jefferson at one point says
to his physician,
"Is it the 4th yet?"
And he says, "No, sir,
it's only the 3rd."
And so Jefferson's got to
hang on a few hours more.
[ Laughter ]
And Adams, the same thing.
He wakes up and he
says, "Is this the 4th?"
And they said, "Yes, sir."
And so he's prepared.
>> David Rubenstein: Right.
>> Gordon Wood: To some
extent they can engineer that.
But they didn't take any
drugs as far as I know.
>> David Rubenstein: So when
Jefferson sends a letter
to Adams or Adams sends
a letter to Jefferson,
how long does it actually
take to get these letters?
>> Gordon Wood: Well, a week.
>> David Rubenstein:
A week or so?
Okay. And when Jefferson
writes a letter,
he has a way of keeping a copy.
How does that work?
>> Gordon Wood: Well, he had
a machine that he had worked
out where he would write
and it would be duplicated.
Jefferson's a gadget man.
And somebody who
loved that kind of --
>> David Rubenstein:
What did Adams do?
>> Gordon Wood: Well, Adams,
I think at one point he's having
somebody write letters for him.
His eyes had become --
>> David Rubenstein: How
did he keep copies of them?
>> Gordon Wood: He would
have them copied over.
>> David Rubenstein: I see.
Now given your expertise
in so many areas,
let's focus on the
Revolutionary War
in the time we have available.
Let me ask you a
couple questions likely
on everybody's mind.
Could we have won
the Revolutionary War
without George Washington?
>> Gordon Wood: Well,
it's hard to think.
I think we could have.
I think someone else
would have emerged.
But it would have
been difficult.
I think more important was
Washington's presidency holding
the sectors together.
The war probably
could have been won.
I think the British after the
initial year really had an
impossible situation, trying to
fight a war 3,000 miles away.
Rebellion of this
sort was similar
to what we faced in Vietnam.
An insurgent population
is not easily put
down when you're so far away.
So I think the British were
doomed from the outset.
>> David Rubenstein:
Do you think they could have
won the war if they had done
or two things differently?
>> Gordon Wood: From the outset
they might have been able
to do it if they'd come in
harshly, but they didn't.
They were conciliatory because
they kept thinking, "Well,
if we're too harsh, we won't
be able to bring them back.
We have to win their
minds and hearts."
And that's not the
way to win war.
And it simply didn't work.
>> David Rubenstein: Now do you
think Jefferson and Washington
and Adams for that matter,
and maybe Benjamin Franklin,
are sitting in heaven saying,
"How come Hamilton has a play
about him and we have no play?"
[ Laughter ]
Was Hamilton really as important
as that play might
indicate, or not?
>> David Rubenstein: Yeah, I
think one thing that's important
which we haven't emphasized
in this conversation is
how different Jefferson
and Adams were from each other.
They differed on every single
major point you could think
of except for the
acceptance of the revolution.
But the one thing they
had in common was a deep
and abiding hatred of
Alexander Hamilton.
[ Laughter ]
Hamilton was important
in consolidating the debt
and getting that
solved at the outset
of Washington's administration.
And that is crucial.
Although that's not
Miranda's point.
Miranda's emphasizing
his immigrant status.
And of course he comes from
Nevis, the West Indies.
He's not in that sense a
member of one of the colonies
that became part of
the United States.
And for Adams, he makes
him out to be a foreigner.
And some historians have
somehow mixed that up.
Of course Nevis is a British
colony and so no different
from Massachusetts
as a British colony.
So Hamilton is as much an
American as John Adams.
But Adams liked to emphasize
that he was a bastard brat,
a foreign bastard brat.
They hated Hamilton,
both of them.
And that's one thing I
think they had in common.
But everything else,
they differed.
They differed on all
men are created equal.
They differed on the
exceptionalism of America
which Jefferson created.
He's the inventor of
American exceptionalism;
we are a special country
with a special role
to play in the world.
Adams said, "That's nonsense.
We are just as vicious, just
as corrupt as other nations."
And Jefferson's notion that
all men are created equal
which of course was the
Enlightenment notion --
it was conventional wisdom
for Enlightenment figures
-- Adams took it on.
Adams took on every myth
that we have as Americans.
He said the idea that we're all
created equal is just poppycock.
And he tells Jefferson
and others, he said,
"I went to a founding hospital
in Paris and I saw babies
who were four days old and
already I saw the inequality.
Some of these babies were
beautiful, some were ugly;
some were smart and some
were stupid at four days."
And so Adams is committed
to the notion of,
if we talk in modern
terms, nature not nurture.
Jefferson and I think Americans
in general at the time,
the enlightened part of
Americans and today I think most
of us are committed to
the idea of nurture.
Adams said, "Don't count on
education to change that.
We're born unequal and
we will remain unequal.
And education can't
do much about it."
That's not a very
American belief.
Jefferson was committed to
the notion of education.
So these two men differ
in fundamental ways
and represent two
different parts of America.
>> David Rubenstein: The
sentence you referred to earlier
in the preamble
of the Declaration is probably
the most famous sentence
in the English language.
"We hold these truths
to be self-evident."
>> Gordon Wood: Right.
>> David Rubenstein: But what
did Jefferson really mean?
He never actually
said what he meant
by all men are created equal.
He had several hundred slaves,
so how could he say all
men were created equal?
What did he really mean?
>> Gordon Wood: He
meant all white men.
But that is not unique
to Jefferson.
Enlightenment figures
at the time --
this is a serious rejection
of the [inaudible] regime
which of course was
committed to the notion of --
they didn't now about DNA.
But they knew about inherited
because they had trained their
animals, if nothing else.
They knew about inheritance
and they believed
in aristocracy running
in the blood.
The Enlightenment is
rejecting that and saying
that that's not what counts.
We are all the same at
birth, and any difference --
and of course they weren't blind
to the differences of adults.
They said, "Of course everyone's
different, but that's due
to different environments, being
raised in different worlds.
And if we can somehow get
the education straight,
we will become more equal."
And this is what
Adams challenges.
I mean, that belief
is fundamental
to our Americanism I think,
that Jeffersonian belief
which is what gives him
his spot in our pantheon.
Adams was taking that on.
He took that on directly
and he took on the notion
of American exceptionalism.
So he's a deep conservative
but not a Ronald
Reagan conservative.
He's sour and cynical
about human nature.
He doubts democracy.
He says, "Sooner or later
our elections will become
so partisan, so corrupt that
we will have to have the Senate
and the president
serve for life.
And eventually they'll have
to become hereditary the way
the English have the House
of Lords and the king."
So he's not a part of
the American mainstream,
but he's realistic, he's
cynical and he is a believer
in what he calls stubborn facts.
>> David Rubenstein:
If you had a chance
to ask John Adams one question
and Jefferson one question,
what would you ask them?
>> Gordon Wood: What I'd
like to know about Jefferson,
why didn't you ever admit
that Sally Hemmings
was your concubine?
Because other planters did.
They recognized their offspring
by giving them presents
at Christmas and so on.
Jefferson has nothing like that.
>> David Rubenstein: He was
accused of this at the time,
but he never admitted
it, never denied it.
>> Gordon Wood: He never admits
it and indirectly denies it.
But he enters the birth of these
offspring in his farm book along
with new heifers and new pigs.
Child born of Sally Hemmings.
That's in his farm book.
Those are his offspring.
He's pretty brutal about that.
>> David Rubenstein: Right.
What would you ask Adams?
>> Gordon Wood: That's
a good question.
Why did he want to
get reconciled
with Thomas Jefferson?
I think that would be
an interesting question.
>> David Rubenstein: Okay.
And if you could summarize
in 30 seconds what you would
like all Americans to know
about the Revolutionary War,
what would be the most
important thing they should know
about the Revolutionary War?
>> Gordon Wood: Look, it's
the most important event
in American history, bar none.
It created, not only legally
created the United States,
but it infused into our
culture all our noblest ideals
and aspirations.
All men are created equal,
liberty, pursuit of happiness.
Think of that phrase.
I just read the speech by
Napal on the universal truth
and he focuses on that phrase.
He says that's an
unbelievable phrase,
that individuals have the
right to pursue happiness.
Think about that.
So the Revolution
creates those ideals.
And that's why it's
such an important event.
That's what Lincoln used to
get through the Civil War.
And if we forget the Revolution,
then we're in trouble.
>> David Rubenstein: So if you'd
like to learn more about this,
Friends Divided, John Adams and
Thomas Jefferson by Gordon Wood.
Thank you very much.
>> Gordon Wood: Thanks, David.
>> David Rubenstein: Thank you.
[ Applause ]